[Musique]
fin juin 2015 c'est une journée tranquille à l'
unité de traitement Ebola de Médecins Sans Frontières à Conakry la
capitale de la Guinée la vitesse peut GDC oncle
Recep Tom DeFalco
un clown psycho Ave focus sur la
buse de Vérone impatiente compétitive nous sommes
interrompus par un appel téléphonique quand  il mas
ANCA confirmant ce qu'ils disent tous
chanson de casino il présentation de l'idée quelques heures
plus tard l'information est transmise au
siège de l'essai du vaccin WH o une
nouvelle victime du bola est ajoutée au
tableau si je clique sur remplissez-moi pour conclure
partout
ils doivent identifier rapidement qui est entré
en contact avec l'enfant l'
épidémie diminue
et c'est peut-être la dernière chance de tester
l'efficacité des vaccins canadiens même
si ce vaccin avec le SAVAK il y a une
dizaine d'années Joseph pompidou est un
juif aigu akashic fois swiss cottage la mulana
L'installation de Trevino
mokou construisant le sous-verre avec des femmes que
vous avez vues à ma signification principale c'est un
Fitbit est une seconde est une seconde c'était
le plus meurtrier Ebola outb  reak sur dossier
et les agents de santé ne pouvaient pas compter sur un
vaccin ou un traitement pour les aider à y faire
face ils ont semé des milliers de leurs
patients et des centaines de collègues sont
morts nous aurions dû voir un
vaccin de révolte avant 29 nous aurions dû avoir qui
étaient dans le congélateur
Ocampo à l'école et je vois un visage un corps se
nourrir en haut me voir en cam pas de
clandestins sur une simple
prospection de quartier Oscar helium hace el Abbas quand l'
économie
[Musique]
après la crise d'Ebola qui a saisi l'
Afrique de l'Ouest pendant des mois, les Ghanéens essaient maintenant
de revenir à  une vie normale et
remettre leur économie sur les rails mais les
panneaux d'affichage partout sont un
rappel constant qu'il est trop tôt donc le
pays doit baisser la garde chaque
bâtiment public surveille la fièvre et
exige que quiconque entre me désinfecte
les mains le Comité National de
Coordination  pour que la
réponse Ebola en Guinée atteigne trois fois par
semaine,
elle doit rendre compte de chaque nouveau cas de
la maladie afin de prévenir une nouvelle
chaîne d'infectio  n à partir de là
ça ne se passe pas pour moi un
peu comme ça il y aura sur
le film la bouffe c'est pas connu pour les
livres gratuits populaires ou les confessionnaux sur la
cuisine tous les partenaires internationaux
se réunissent ici les CDC médecins sans
frontières les français  gouvernement même l'
agence de santé publique du Canada partenaires
qui doivent parfois être confrontés à
la dure réalité de la vie quotidienne en
Guinée
[Musique]
les procès pour crime comprenaient l'Inde un
inutile à l'effort international conjoint
est loin de la situation
il y a 15 mois  quand tout le monde a apparemment
ignoré ou refusé de reconnaître la
crise d'Ebola qui allait devenir la
plus meurtrière de l'histoire, la super demande alias
pirate ah da da da da la a procédé à une
cassette photo conique mélodica maman a
incité la cooper - aankia shadow est-ce que
vous Jerry
compensez c'est la même épidémie  dans une
tragédie de revers mars 2014 les premiers cas
d'Ebola ont été officiellement identifiés dans
le village de DK c'était une
souche zaïroise la plus meurtrière  c'était la première
fois que le virus apparaissait en Guinée une
équipe médicale d'urgence de Médecins
sans frontières a été dépêchée le personnel s'est
vite rendu compte que cette épidémie était
différente Lukas malaria Vedika
a pour en déduire un deuxième kilo-octet la
distance sur CDC Rama quand je le crois
dans sept zones géographiques clés  la créatrice de masse
est laide
manoosh indique APIs console Vickers
City personne commune Allemand vomit Alderman
[Musique]
au cours des deux mois suivants
, les nombreux appels à l'aide de l'organisation sont tombés
dans l'oreille d'un sourd
ni le gouvernement guinéen ni l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé n'ont pris des mesures en
partie pour éviter de causer  panique et blessant
l'économie du pays
pendant ce temps l'épidémie a atteint la
capitale Conakry et les pays voisins la
Sierra Leone et le Libéria la
tequila d'un avocat KPI
assiste à une mélodie commune voir Tahiry yo la
première persona cirque mi ke ke liye
telecom amanada modalité visuelle au sein du
LMPD ils ont  un souvenir commun Umar
Torre et son frère Sekou sont des
survivants de  Ebola,
ils ont perdu six membres de leur famille
lors de l'épidémie, ils ont tous deux passé
trois semaines dans un centre de traitement Ebola.
Le frère aîné de Kumar est mort dans ses bras.
réparer la couche isolante à la rébellion
militante imaginer l'ennemi opératif le
Pokémon dans le film Pishin rétine mon frere
il a été fait un ciel bouddhiste et en ruine
dans notre souci de genre particulier de bricoleur faire
pour ce cours j'ai appelé l'autorité de l'oncle
pour collecter des dimensions etc faire de la musique
quand l'épidémie a commencé  les autorités
des pays touchés ont répété le même
message à la population Ebola est un
virus mortel pour lequel il n'y a pas de remède,
par conséquent, beaucoup refusent de se rendre dans
les centres de traitement, recourant parfois à la
violence comme moyen de résistance,
contribuant davantage à la propagation du virus
ELISA  Caractère de Becker dans la clé de la mélodie pour
accréter la deuxième fosse ouais mais khatma si
vous en avouez un universel avec de
cosmonaute  plus de temps un morceau une
solution polynomiale facilement super-sexy
samox pauvre Petey piranha
il y a eu des cas où des
agents de santé ont été attaqués au début de
l'épidémie toutes sortes de rumeurs ont alimenté la méfiance à l'
égard du médecin visité effets mmm
selon examiner dans ' un cube comme
celui-ci apprivoisé  un billet est un souvenir pour
neuf segments sur les affaires d'Ebola
peu de retard affaires aqua de la taupe
compréhension trommel compréhension
château détracteur o Aleman prendre une salade
rembourser la recherche incrémentale milady
alguien un membre donné jorgen résultat
nous avons vu la victime dr.  Wesley mâle ou CMD
physique a déclaré Aviles Kaioken aujourd'hui un
cas non - des individus honky contrôlent une
population définie dans l'avantage de
la mélodie J'apprécierais la déclaration merde d'Allah le
Fed kannadi kappa du Midi généralement le
vaccin un confesseur alwa relation et
non-partie pas de compartiments aussi  un
contrôle des tortues installant rapidement
[Musique] la
peur et la méfiance ont affecté non seulement la
population en général, mais se sont également étendues aux
agents de santé, ce qui a rendu de
plus en plus difficile leur recrutement.
de nous
recueillons un peu plus une partie manque
étant donné la particule Italie Oh dévasté asila
via del skeevy damn MCO medida million
enquête Pahlavi Nia
Bakura Fidel Devaney [ __ ] un
moment remarquable nous avons une fête Damona n'importe qui notre
sens commun de la fraternité réduit la
conscience à la place estas cosas de de
Foix sur ma par exemple Jerry futur
Kalkan Chili affirmant la règle et ma ma
polygamie Papa voyage  cas un pionnier du
spa Karina s'opposera au système de santé
des pays touchés était déjà
fragile et ne pouvait pas faire face à l'
épidémie il y avait une pénurie de
tout, des fournitures aux
équipements de protection, même la formation au virus a décimé
la main-d'œuvre les centres de traitement gérés par
Médecins Sans Frontières étaient  tendu
et surmené
un nombre record d'
agents de santé de l'organisation ont été infectés en
trois mois l'épidémie s'est propagée à plus
de 60 endroits différents Médecins
sans frontières a publié une déclaration
décrivant l'épidémie comme
incontrôlable sendou costume Carnegie dans la Sierra
Nevada applaudir une casita supers dire à
maman  Tenma difícil a pasta de swamp ser
el Ojo zeus isa khans ignore un nouveau
fala de l'OPIC avant la mousson le méga jésus prend
soin du camélia
[Musique] d'
autres ont appelé à la même chose
Jeremy Farrar dirige le Wellcome Trust,
la deuxième fondation caritative la plus dépensière au monde
en  problèmes de santé, je
me souviens avoir écrit à ce sujet en juin
appelant à  des études sur les médicaments et les
vaccins et je me souviens encore maintenant qu'à
ce moment-là en juin, il y avait 200 décès,
vous savez, à la fin de l'année,
c'était vers dix dix deux
mille dix mille décès et plus, je
[Musique
] déclare le courant  épidémie de
maladie à virus Ebola une
urgence de santé publique de portée internationale
août 2014 des milliers de personnes étaient déjà mortes
d'Ebola au moment où l'OMS a
déclaré l'apparition d'une crise sanitaire
mondiale appelant le monde à se mobiliser
l'organisation a décidé d'autoriser
l'utilisation de traitements et de
médicaments expérimentaux  dans les pays touchés mais il y
avait un problème,
aucun des produits pharmaceutiques n'était
prêt à être utilisé sur des humains pour dire Civics
on America mo trompé sur camasta cray
cray Nina's purse confetti Rihanna
Bianco très spécial sur CD solution yo yo
yo le associe un Ramos faible dividende
Orgazmo dilemmes vous féroce
en 1976 une équipe internationale de médecins a
atterri à l'igname Bakou un an une
maladie mystérieuse avec  terrifiant la
population locale Le microbiologiste belge Peter
Piot et ses collègues ont découvert un nouveau
virus et l'ont appelé Ebola du nom de
la rivière qui traverse la région
jusqu'à il y a deux mois les médecins ne savaient même pas
que ce virus existait ils le savent maintenant
car des centaines de personnes infectées  par
lui sont morts
depuis lors, il y a eu 23
épidémies distinctes en Afrique affectant des dizaines à des
centaines de personnes à chaque fois que le virus
était généralement isolé dans des zones reculées et
n'a jamais vraiment attiré
l'attention internationale, surtout de la
part de l'industrie pharmaceutique,
mais c'était avant les événements  du 11 septembre
une semaine après les attentats de New York, des
lettres contenant de l'anthrax ont été envoyées par
la poste, tuant cinq personnes
aux autorités américaines.  tourné leur
attention vers des agents pathogènes qui pourraient être
utilisés par des terroristes, y compris le virus Ebola,
l'augmentation du financement de
la guerre biologique aux États-Unis
et au Canada a suscité de nouvelles recherches sur les
vaccins et les traitements au fil des ans. Le
Canada a dépensé sept millions de dollars pour la
recherche sur Ebola, comme Apache Dupree.
à la demande Latasha
les cellules montrées être allergiques ajoutées
logique manasvi voir comme ministère de la
Défense et d'autres Canada kiasu botanique
est pour tkq le premier ou bactérie
technologie viejo dr.  Gary Kobinger est en
demande en tant qu'orateur public il ne fait rien
il est actuellement chef des
agents pathogènes spéciaux au Laboratoire national de microbiologie
de Winnipeg le seul
site de niveau quatre de biosécurité au Canada
où des travaux sont menés sur certains
des organismes les plus dangereux au monde il
est arrivé au  laboratoire en 2005 reprenant le
travail qui avait déjà commencé sur le
vaccin ses nombreuses visites sur le terrain en Afrique les ont
aidés à acquérir une connaissance de première main de
la dévastation causée par la maladie
le rythme du plaidoyer des colonies le rythme rapide
développer un vaccin que les gens connaissent plus tard un
brahmane ou CTE trois populations
si Daniel Nava zéro donc en 2005 le
laboratoire a fièrement annoncé qu'il avait
développé un vaccin prouvé
efficace chez les primates
à coup sûr ce travail est certainement je pense que l'
une des plus grandes réalisations de cette
installation la prochaine étape était de le tester sur l'
homme et d'obtenir le  organismes de réglementation pour l'
approuver, la première étape consiste bien sûr
à fabriquer un vaccin cliniquement utilisable pour l'homme
et cela doit être d  un par une
société commerciale ayant une expertise dans le
développement ce n'est pas le genre de chose que
cet établissement peut prendre à la recherche d'
une société pharmaceutique a commencé il
serait responsable de mettre le vaccin
sur le marché efficace une
expérience de carnaval au travail alors allez je suis dedans  un
poste sur Mars Laboral une clinique
Christophe ne peut pas me voir sourire un
requin chef bénéficiaire est un système de tous les mon
propre genou coton bouche voir ce processus
s'est avéré plus difficile que
prévu personne ne semblait intéressé à
acquérir la licence vaccinale cela a pris
cinq ans  pour trouver un
partenaire pharmaceutique aux états-unis  nama est une
zone articulée le de zaak elle cuisine wah miss
public Peter Monte assez juste pour
secouer mon non pas c'est une coruña
pornographe comparaisons CPS le pokey
crénelé l'effet plus délicat une
philosophie fatsia Aveo sake Pavel Erica
laboratoire vectoriel kippa co extrait Hawaii dans
une entreprise époxy  new link PG commandes ici
au missile Excellence Thomas fire
exit Iowa new link genetics est une petite
société de biotechnologie basée dans l'Iowa en
2010 sa division des systèmes de protection biologique a
payé deux cent cinq mille
dollars pour acquérir la licence du vaccin
[Musique]
il est impossible de  suivre le
nombre de personnes infectées qui affluent
dans nos installations en Sierra Leone et
les corps des appareils pourrissent dans les
rues le 2 septembre 2014 Médecins
sans frontières a lancé un autre
appel désespéré cette fois aux Nations Unies
qu'il y avait un besoin urgent d'un
soutien tangible dans  le terrain avec une pression
croissante, le w-h-o a convoqué une
réunion spéciale à Genève avec plus de 200
fonctionnaires sci  entists philanthropes et
représentants de l'
industrie pharmaceutique comment pouvons-nous prendre les choses
qui sont le MOL restant de cette
alerte critique non prouvée et nous
assurer qu'elles sont là à long terme avec la
plus grande vitesse possible dans un effort pour
arrêter l'épidémie le w-h-o a donné le
vert  lumière pour accélérer un processus qui
prend généralement des années, nous avons dit regardez nous sommes
prêts à financer des idées centrales pour déplacer
les traitements de diagnostic vaccin, puis
nous avons dit que nous allons accélérer et je veux dire
accélérer je veux dire prendre des décisions en quelques
heures ou jours et puis  mettre des fonds à la
disposition des candidats les plus prometteurs
dans ces domaines
[Musique]
huit traitements expérimentaux et deux
vaccins ont été sélectionnés, dont le
vaccin canadien vsv evolution, en partie
parce qu'ils en contenaient déjà 1 500
flacons dr.  Maggie Puccini espérait que les vaccins
seraient distribués en novembre 2014 aux
agents de santé de première ligne, vous n'avez
qu'environ 120 minutes dans votre costume et vous
avez tous ces patients parfois
nous serrions la bouteille du
patient à côté de la personne
examinait donc j'étais  faire cela avec un
tas de bouteilles et il y avait un tas
d'aiguilles dedans et j'ai retiré les
aiguilles parce que je ne voulais pas
me coller j'ai marché jusqu'à l'endroit où les
conteneurs pour objets tranchants étaient censés être
et ils étaient tous pleins alors j'ai déménagé  l'
aiguille et l'a enfoncée dans mon
pouce
[Musique]
c'est arrivé fin septembre 2014
à Kenema Sierra Leone dr.  Luis Robinson
faisait du bénévolat avec les conditions w-h-
o à l'hôpital étaient tout
simplement chaotiques ma première réaction était
ok je ne le dis à personne, vous
savez, je ne veux tout simplement pas m'occuper de
ça maintenant je suis fatigué et puis j'ai commencé
sentir le saignement dans mon pouce et je suis
comme si d'accord maintenant, je dois en quelque sorte vous
savoir gérer cela moins de 48 heures
plus tard, il était à bord d'un jet privé
en route pour les États-Unis. Les autorités américaines lui ont
proposé un choix d'expérimentation
traitements et vaccins,
il a choisi le vaccin canadien, donc
dès que je suis monté dans l'avion, j'ai signé
le consentement et ils l'ont mis dans mon
bras si mal que nous décollions,
j'avais la possibilité de vous laisser savoir
quand d'autres personnes sont tombées malades  là, parmi les
habitants, ils ont été placés dans l'
unité de traitement d'Ebola, vous savez, et c'est là
qu'un certain nombre d'entre eux sont morts et ces
gens travaillent depuis des mois,
vous savez, je suis saint, j'étais là depuis trois
semaines, donc il y avait une certaine culpabilité à propos de ces
tests sanguins  finalement  est revenu
négatif
dr.  Rueben n'a jamais contracté Ebola
parce que je suis né en Amérique,
vous savez que j'ai accès à quelque chose et
si vous êtes né en Sierra Leone,
désolé, votre vie ne vaut pas autant 40
agents de santé sont morts à l'hôpital de Kenema
pendant l'épidémie
la plupart des travailleurs internationaux qui
ont été infectés ont été évacués tandis que beaucoup
d'entre eux ont eu accès à des médicaments expérimentaux
la majorité de leurs collègues ouest-africains
n'ont pas eu la chance de
devoir attendre que les essais cliniques aient
commencé
[Music]
you
on  8 octobre 2014 Le Libérien Thomas Duncan est
décédé dans un hôpital du Texas, il a été la
première victime d'Ebola sur le sol américain.
Deux infirmières qui l'ont soigné ont également été
infectées ce soir.
peur et panique à travers les
états-unis  Ebola n'était plus confiné à l'
Afrique les travailleurs humanitaires internationaux ont été
traqués par les autorités et les
médias certains ont été mis en quarantaine même lorsqu'ils
ne présentaient aucun symptôme le nombre de
personnes atteintes d'Ebola dans ces zones
pourrait atteindre 1,4 million d'ici le 20 janvier la
peur d'une épidémie mondiale  envoyé des
ondes de choc à travers le marché boursier les
sociétés de biotechnologie travaillant sur Ebola ont vu
leurs actions monter en flèche
soudainement le vaccin v / s de ba était un
produit chaud un nouveau lien a conclu un
accord de licence avec le géant pharmaceutique
Merck pour 50 millions de dollars la même
licence a acheté un deux cent et  cinq
mille dollars
Byron Amin est un analyste de recherche
couvrant le domaine de la biotechnologie pour
Jeffrey's à New York La génétique de Newland
est l'une des sociétés qu'il suit
avant l'épidémie que saviez-vous
très peu de ce vaccin contre Ebola, je
veux dire que l'accent principal pour le nouveau lien
est en grande partie  dans le développement de thérapies contre le cancer, de
sorte que la société n'avait pas
vraiment parlé et parlé de leur
programmes de développement dans le domaine des
maladies infectieuses telles que le vaccin contre Ebola, les petites
entreprises de biotechnologie comme New Link
fonctionnent avec un déficit depuis des années en
attendant l'opportunité de lancer un
produit révolutionnaire sur le marché. Les
actionnaires miaulants sont actuellement très
optimistes quant à un traitement prometteur contre le cancer du pancréas.
Le vaccin Ebola n'était
pas une priorité, il serait très
difficile pour eux, il nécessiterait beaucoup de
ressources et cela détournerait
leur attention du développement de
thérapies à des fins oncologiques vers
un vaccin contre Ebola dans le
domaine pharmaceutique. chaque nouveau médicament a besoin d'un marché pour les
investisseurs I  cela signifie clairement qu'ils
recherchent un marché attractif et donc quand
vous pensez au vaccin contre Ebola en tant que marché,
ce n'est pas quelque chose que l'on peut quantifier
facilement et je pense que c'est là que réside la
difficulté et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'ils éviteraient
Je ne veux pas les attaquer et je
ne veux vraiment pas je veux dire mais c'est dans  ce
monde la capacité de développer des vaccins
malheureusement ou heureusement c'est vraiment
très étroit c'est principalement la principale
société de vaccins ce n'est pas la biotechnologie
ce n'est pas
dr.  Adel Mahmood est un expert de premier plan des
maladies infectieuses dans le
monde en développement, il a été président de Merck Vaccins
de 1998 à 2006, il pense que seules les
grandes sociétés pharmaceutiques ont l'
infrastructure et les ressources pour développer des
vaccins et les mettre sur le marché, mais
elles veulent aussi revenir sur  leur
investissement, l'agence de santé publique a
déclaré avoir contacté de nombreuses entreprises, parmi
lesquelles de grandes sociétés pharmaceutiques, et elles ont toutes
dit non merci,
donc si le calcul démontre
que vous n'avez pas de marché potentiel
pour que le produit récupère vos dépenses,
je veux dire pour développer un  vaccin depuis le
début de la découverte jusqu'au déploiement
du vaccin en tant que produit,
le coût moyen est d'un milliard de dollars par
milliard d'euros bain le nouveau lien d'accord pourquoi
ont-ils autorisé le produit de l'
agence de santé publique du Canada, je suppose que
c'est parce qu'ils  se rendent compte qu'il existe des
sources d'argent disponibles dans
ce pays qu'ils pourraient
exploiter, donc des subventions du
gouvernement  Les subventions de financement du gouvernement au
fil des ans, New Link Genetics, ont
reçu plus de sept millions de dollars
de subventions du département américain de la Défense
pour la recherche sur diverses
maladies infectieuses, mais il n'y a aucune mention de travaux
spécifiquement effectués sur le
vaccin VSD Evolve dans leurs communiqués de presse
ou  rapports financiers, nous retrouvons l'
ancien scientifique du laboratoire de Winnipeg qui est
allé travailler pour un nouveau lien, il dit qu'il n'a jamais
vu de travail entrepris sur le vaccin dont nous avons
besoin pour travailler dans le laboratoire que nous
n'avons pas fait sur ce vaccin qui est
pendant cette période et je  y avait-il Ramone
Flick était le chef des vaccins
de biodéfense jusqu'en 2013 à cause de l'
énorme mal qui le faisait aller aux seins avant
que c'était plutôt sur un brûleur bas en
raison de la plage de profit pas si potentielle que
vous savez
quand le nouveau lien a acquis une licence  droits
du Canada le contrat obligeait l'
entreprise à déployer
des efforts commercialement raisonnables l'entreprise Pampas la
merced pas de LM dans la machine X Isola  nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de plaire à une belle attitude,
car la charge de maman peut laisser un plafond au
mannequin, certaines géométries d'entreprise
sont attendues, la libération d'emote d'un jeûne
plus élevé pour élever notre désir de plan principal
dans l'onglet religieux nécessairement
niveler le cercle par una légendes du talc de la grand-mère de John
moins d'attitude au Canada seulement 70
des plus pauvres ont cette technique de base sur
les serviteurs des pauvres je suis économique elle
parce qu'on met l'accent en Irak en 2010 l'
agence de santé publique a produit 1500 flacons
pour d'autres tests sur les animaux le Canada a
payé huit cent quatre vingt sept
mille dollars  pour eux, en théorie, une nouvelle
longueur était censée intervenir et commencer
des essais cliniques sur des humains en
neurologie focale la clinique de développement Dada
Parkin Apple la fosse
suppose que je vais matalava rasathi Carmela
performance de la clinique le père la
pnina pnina go paga VCC de notre
sécurité mais  Je fais équipe avec ceux qui le font lorsque
le
sceau de la diversité de la personne du cycle accompagne prépare une
confirmation Arizona Nouveau-Mexique dala
dala fall  La société daca erica affirme dans
un quatuor en tant qu'accompagnateur formel un
dépôt et Asahikawa calsilica mozzie
Cesar a déclaré que le père dépose de l'aluminium sur
l'agence a refusé de nous dire ce que le
plan d'affaires impliquait et nous ne savons pas non plus
quels suivis avec l'entreprise ont été
effectués par  l'agence de santé nos
demandes d'accès à l'information n'ont pas
reçu de réponse nouveau lien a refusé de commenter la
caméra mais a plutôt répondu par un
courriel la société prétend avoir fait un
travail considérable sur le
vaccin en collaboration avec l'
agence de santé publique canadienne nouveau lien le
dit  était en train de
négocier avec les autorités fédérales et
était presque prêt pour les essais cliniques
lorsque l'épidémie a commencé, mais selon l'
ex-employé Ramon Flick, l'entreprise avait du
mal à obtenir des subventions gouvernementales, mais
seulement comme un déportable, donnez-en au
tribunal, ils ne sont généralement pas discutés
sur la façon d'obtenir un financement, mais dans la mesure
où je suis devenu un sentier m6 au moment de
l'épidémie, il n'y avait pas eu de test  g
sur les humains, la crise grandissait et
des mois précieux étaient perdus
[Musique]
ces blessures dans les Aléoutiennes et l'
agitation alors que le nombre de morts augmentait le w-h-o
était en retard et acheminait le
vaccin vers les lignes de front mais en
décembre le taux d'infection dans  L'
Afrique de l'Ouest a commencé à dissiper la question dans
l'esprit de tout le monde s'il y aurait maintenant
suffisamment de cas pour entreprendre des
essais cliniques et déterminer son
efficacité  les
agents de santé nous emmènent au village
où l'enfant est mort d'Ebola aujourd'hui les
personnes qui ont été en contact avec la
victime recevront l'université de performance du système canadien de
thermalisation de l'après-midi
s'il y a des preuves pour Alma d'accord la
phase finale des essais de vaccination à
tester  l'efficacité du vaccin a commencé
il y a trois mois en Guinée avec
les agents de santé de première ligne et la
communauté touchée, mais c'est une course
ag  À l'heure actuelle, il n'y a plus qu'une
poignée de cas par semaine, ce qui
compromet peut-être les résultats des essais excusables
qu'ils gardent typiques de l'UNAM dr.  G sur l'
analyseur résident du cercle qui est une
parabole très lisible très gênante pour
le 190e analphabétisme Angelita Les Nonna
sont évitables au moment où nous arrivons le
processus de vaccination est bien engagé
il y a beaucoup de participants parmi les
villageois et les choses se passent
bien la circoncision chez un économiste est
non c'est pas tous oakum Sebastia kuzu
de resistance convert kimia kamsa
yah-yah-yah-yah ma de la nación de la
paz de la población avec Cassidy
message de veto si la population reste
méfiante à propos d'Ebola,
les équipes de vaccination doivent  d'abord
rassurer les gens tout en restant vigilant
pour des raisons de sécurité le
processus de vaccination se déroule sur la
propriété des chefs locaux visible ce mouvement nous - qui
donnerons exemple un crédit en
servant avec l'emprunter un intervenant
nous dire est réel sachez ce que vous n'êtes pas la
sensibilité ne sera pas  sois précis alors
ils disent que je t'aime comme tes devoirs tu
sais mon pote tu vois c'est encore complètement plat
jeune Weller  est sur l'enthalpie certaines
filles sont vaccinées immédiatement
après une éventuelle exposition à un nouveau
cas d'autres comme celle-ci sont
vaccinées trois semaines plus tard qui est
la période d'incubation de la maladie
l'idée est de comparer le nombre de nouvelles
infections dans les deux groupes donc notre nouveau
fait face à Abba donde la Santa Ana ho gracias
muchacha de la mala disque sur Malastare no
Salma la vela ne manifeste pas de catastrophe
pour la suite amil kanika seperti mon
nom est l'école RuPaul et une méthodologie
affaire de gaufres de Cornouailles vomi raser un
environnement fonctionne effets nah c'est
Jessica le pire de l'épidémie est
passé mais l'espoir est maintenant de développer une
arme pour combattre la prochaine épidémie la plupart
des autres vaccins et traitements
testés pendant l'épidémie ont montré
des résultats décevants soit à cause d'
un nombre décroissant de cas comme au
Libéria soit parce que  ils se sont avérés
inefficaces nous pensons que le monde est
sur le point d'avoir un
vaccin efficace contre Ebola un mois après notre
équipe de production  s'est rendu en Guinée le w-h-o a
publié les résultats préliminaires de l'
essai le vaccin canadien s'est avéré
efficace à 100 %
parmi les personnes vaccinées immédiatement il n'y a
eu aucun nouveau cas dans le deuxième groupe
vacciné trois semaines plus tard 16 personnes ont
été infectées
les essais cliniques ont été menés en un temps
record  temps bonne nouvelle pour l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé qui a fait l'
objet de critiques croissantes pour sa réponse tardive à l'
épidémie, mais pour Joanne savait quelle
organisation avait participé à l'essai,
le succès laisse un
goût doux-
amer  que se passe discuter d'une
certaine époque dire kombucha prothétique un
si paresseux dire pardon artistes persona
résident bulu animo para para dit melio
una rapport fait face à l'acide est une promenade Oh un
Patek honore un esclave nouvelle maison
diront-ils ma pomme de terre pour me montrer
dans le
Omar et Saku Tory, survivants de la capitale, tentent
de reconstituer leur vie  là encore,
ils ont été pris en charge par une fourmi, ils
sont de retour à l'école, mais ils sont maintenant confrontés à
des exemples de préjugés continus, nous ne vous avons pas
pardonné avec quelques densités différentes, les
victimes ont été trouvées plus
contaminées et potentiellement quelque chose de
religieux sera divertissant. Jakarta
serait d'accord, ils  besoin d'être là où le yoga sans
[ __ ] de propriétaire sera toujours une maladie
des pays relativement pauvres et
éventuellement probablement de l'Afrique subsaharienne
et donc il n'y a pas de marché là
-bas qui va payer les sortes de montants
qui vont être nécessaires dans mon
je pense que c'est la vraie santé publique et donc je pense que cela doit être une combinaison de
contribuable public et de philanthropie et d'
industrie à l'avenir
lorsque nous faisons cette recherche scientifique fondamentale,
nous devons la mener à un point où
si quelque chose se produit, nous pouvons vraiment
accélérer  si vous obtenez les chances que vous veniez sixième
forme nécessaire une amorce de la ville principale en développement
sukham asanam woodling p4 l'
identité de twala avec ipython notre siège de poker nous avons
ret beaucoup ke  eps sur le buzzer prioritaire, donc
exci comme ça, complètement tombé,
voyez le vaccin canadien maintenant autorisé par
Merck n'a pas encore été approuvé par les
autorités sanitaires telles que la FDA
dans l'intervalle, Merck s'est engagé à
mettre 300 000 $ à disposition en cas de
nouvelle urgence, pensez-vous  pense que sans
cette épidémie de 2014, nous aurions vu
un jour un vaccin contre Ebola que nous aurions dû avoir
parce que les vaccins candidats qui étaient
dans le congélateur
ont été découverts vers la fin du
20e siècle au début du 21e
siècle, ils étaient donc dans le congélateur
le Canadien  le voyage des vaccins n'est pas un
cas unique d'autres remèdes prometteurs restent
dans les limbes et ce que l'
industrie pharmaceutique appelle la vallée de la mort la
transition très coûteuse entre la
découverte d'un médicament et sa mise sur le
marché
il existe de nombreux produits comme celui-ci pour des
maladies qui sont les congélateurs à droite  maintenant
SARS MERS Fièvre de Lassa Poulet de Marburg
Goya Virus Nipah nous sourions Je veux dire la
liste s'allonge encore et encore allez
Scull  y show seeker miséricorde innée probablement
partie macula déjouer epidemy nutella
appliquer comme une paire d'un garçon bola j'étais
quelques-uns ont choisi un
akyurek un kebab ou ce que j'appelle un
interprète alors s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
aha